you have made your prediction and now
it's time to see what happens when I
release the balance ready in 3 2 1 the
balance tips towards the right towards
the hanging heavier ball but why does
this happen well the best way I can
think of to explain this is that both
balls displace the same amount of water
so they both experienced the same upward
buoyant force which is equal to the
weight of the water they displace that's
just Archimedes principle but by
Newton's third law that means there must
be equal and opposite forces down on the
water in both beakers so you would think
that both beakers would get heavier by
this same amount now for the hanging
ball the beaker does get heavier by this
amount because the buoyant force is now
supporting some of the weight that used
to be supported by this tension in the
string but it's now reduced and so the
beaker actually has more weight but for
the ping pong ball the downward force on
the water is almost entirely
counteracted by the upward force of the
tension in that string on the bottom of
the beaker and therefore the weight of
this beaker only increases by the weight
of the ping pong ball itself whereas for
the hanging ball the weight increases by
the weight of water it displaces so
obviously this beaker is going to end up
being heavier now I want to propose an
additional experiment what if instead of
tethering the ping pong ball to the base
of this beaker I just got a free ping
pong ball and submerged it with my
finger just barely under the surface of
the water in that case what do you think
would happen when the scale was allowed
to rotate would it tilt down a towards
the hanging acrylic ball or B down
towards the ping pong ball which is now
just barely submerged into the water or
see where the balance remain perfectly
balanced so I want you to make your
selection make your prediction by
leaving a comment
starting with either a B or C and then
giving me your explanation and I'll
tally up the votes and let you know the
answer next time
you